[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
as you guys can clearly see
we all have the hater blockers on today
we all have the hater blockers on uh not
today we haven't you know we haven't hit
a parlay since Ryan since when since
before Christ BC yeah yeah
it's been that long so we gotta switch
up The Vibes and we're throwing on the
hater blocker so uh if you're with us we
need the the sunglasses emojis in the
comments but guys
today's been wild yesterday's been well
this week's been wild in the NBA in the
NBA
but I'm I guess like I I'm I'm I'm lost
for words like I'm really sad that KD is
a Sons
I'm sad that Katie's on the Suns he
should have been a warrior
should have been a warrior he's been a
woman no no he's we should have got him
back
ship Wise Men ship Wiggins ship uh Moody
and like seven first round picks get KD
back to the Warriors what are we doing
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait
you're gonna have to include pool and
kaminga in that deal you put it you
couldn't pull into MinGa in that deal
maybe Steph Curry
off limits those guys are not not
negotiable
KD how is that how is that trade work
without those guys
I mean
that's where the seven round that's
where the seven first round picks come
in Ryan come on now
seven first round picks is hilarious
yeah
what that's damn near what Brooklyn how
many first round picks did they get like
four or four no I know but you're gonna
be miserable in five years because
you're gonna be like oh my God we got
Katie and we still lost the Celtics in
the finals and then you're gonna be like
ah now we suck we have no future to be
like I know I tried to tell you Greg
that's when we start the show
Q to start the show we need the lower
Graphics uh uh yeah can we can we get
the lower thirds please because it's
time to start the show welcome to the
show my name is Greg Ivory next to me is
Michael Bolin the man of the app and
next to him is uh the male we like to
call Double R producer Ryan that's no
that's new that is new that isn't it
yeah I like that though it has a ring to
it I like it yeah there's there's gonna
be some haters in the chat uh who are
gonna say Triple R for for the rats um
but I'm getting out ahead of you
no I'm yeah I'm getting out ahead of it
and I'm letting you know I've got the
sunglasses on and I don't care okay the
chat's witty the chat's witty they they
were gonna do that I know that
uh Ryan you you you did that to yourself
bro like you you did that to yourself
but let's look at how the KD trade
impacted Futures Ryan let's pull up the
Futures on
FanDuel let's see what they're talking
about
because I'm I'm bro I'm so sad like
I'm so mad that KD is a son like I'm so
upset
dude they went from 1901 to plus 480
overnight
we did see that ticket of of someone
getting them right two hours before the
debt or but before the trade was made
that guy's probably feeling pretty good
right now for sure
I would assume so yeah I'm sick but you
know who else is feeling good me as a
former Bulls fan I put some money down
on the sons when this rumor popped up oh
so long ago and I didn't cash it out so
I'm sitting on a on a on a ticket for
the Suns to win the title and when I
woke up this morning I thought it was a
dream but we're back in the money baby
it looks pretty good right now but when
you say oh so long ago when you say it
was so long ago are you referring to the
summer
I am
so that number wasn't 1901. no no no no
okay it's it it was twelve to one okay
all right I still got some value yeah
yeah but hey bullet
I'm sorry go ahead no no go ahead what's
up because I was I was just gonna say
hold your horses like don't get too
excited don't don't be proclaiming that
the suns are going to win the title
because the Warriors Got Gary Payton the
second back he is a championship player
a championship staple on our team we got
him back
feeling good about it feeling good
out of there Gary Payton yeah I I like
the move he definitely is a fan favorite
amongst Warriors fans I could tell over
the last few years so getting him back
is actually a pretty big deal and once
they get healthy they're still gonna be
very scary
it is the Warriors are so far down on
this list you can't even see the Celtics
anymore that's I mean what are we doing
I had to hit show more to see the
Warriors title Lots why are we talking
about the Warriors hey that's when you
go take them now that's when you go why
are we talking about the Warriors don't
forget Ryan they are the defending
champs
the way they've started off this season
it's very easy to forget their defending
Chumps because that's what they are this
year at the Chumps Hey listen listen
those are our loser of the finals are
the Chumps you know listen Double R we
are just anxiously awaiting for Jason
Tatum to disappear in the playoffs again
so don't you forget don't start this
yeah yeah if you
go bowling on on Twitter every now and
again you get you got a Michael bowling
like that it's Jason Tatum slander and
I've been meaning to bring it up to you
but it's been pissing me off every time
I open the app just letting you know you
already know what time it is because I
don't know he's not he's not gonna be
any kind of MVP caliber guy until he
comes through in the playoffs that's
just how I see it
I agree you know who was locking them up
in the playoffs taking turns locking
them up who Gary Payton II
so we have a Tatum stop or is what
you're saying I'm just maybe I won't go
that far I'm you know Jason said he is a
baller he's a boy I won't go that far
but uh the warriors were throwing a lot
of men a lot of guys at his way A lot of
guys his way to defend him and uh gp2
Greg
I can't you cannot I can't remember last
year I mean you know I think that's the
most recent that's the most recent
Champions this is the Warriors but let's
let's you you you're talking about last
year I mean Ryan you don't want to talk
about last year nope but unfortunately
we we have to talk about last week
Brooke Lopez Grayson Allen cemented
themselves
on our betting band list yeah sure do
not bet forever
I I feel really sick about it I don't
even know
we knew we knew we should have just
skipped it we knew why we knew
especially
why in the world was Grace and Allen on
our ticket
I I've asked the same question about
Austin Reeves and Dante divincenzo many
times before but we do this to ourselves
we always get we always talk ourselves
into the guys whose regular over under
is like eight points
why why do we do that
I don't know well the only the only
thing I can say guys is we got to throw
the whole rule book out and just start
from scratch today
hey we acting brand new today y'all see
us with the glasses y'all see us with
the hater blocker Zone we acting real
brand new today but we bout to hit cause
it's time to move on from last week
and cook up a winner for this week drop
your Best Bets for tonight's TNT games
in the chat we're talking Bulls Nets
bucks Lakers Ryan what are the people in
the chat talking about
uh darian85
my guy it's always I'm always gonna call
out darian85 first uh he goes uh oh
y'all too too cool for school today and
he goes I hope y'all can see a w tonight
through those glasses yeah I hope so too
Darian I hope I could see a W-2 but
guess what I haven't seen a w in quite a
long time so
listen all we we talked we discussed
something briefly before the show the
first play in the chat is Cam Thomas 50
piece 50 piece shout out to spicy sponge
this is so funny
oh my goodness let's see where where are
we at this piece a 50 Burger he's not
even thinking competitive no no no you
definitely can't you can go up to 35 and
cam Thomas is five to one
listen I have I'm gonna do a little TSA
and then I'm gonna get out of the way I
have a couple Stone Cold locks when it
comes to Bulls basketball but one of two
teams that didn't make a single move
this trade deadline the Cleveland
Cavaliers and the Chicago Bulls so I am
officially hanging up my Bulls fandom
and I'm reaching up for the sun's fandom
because clearly my team doesn't want to
be involved and they think that just
like doing the same thing over and over
is going to get you something
um you've been hanging around Ryan too
much bro
I gotta get you we got to get you back
to your to being yourself listen bowling
knows this bowling knows this sometimes
you need to go and you need to get a win
you're not going to get that with no
offense no offense I want to I want to
you know preempt this you're not gonna
get that with the Chicago Bulls I would
like to say there were rumors of Indiana
Pacers for you can you confirm or deny
I'm getting close man I really like
Tyrese Halliburton I think he's really
great
um I don't know we'll see man I'm just
sick of them doing the same things over
and over but in terms of a parlay I got
some plays that I think might might help
us get there tonight all right all right
first leg first leg let's get into this
parlay because uh
I'm I'm getting restless I'm I'm I want
some money okay I want some money so
we've got we've got flyman that says
Dinwiddie 20 plus he's at 20 and a half
that's his point total right now uh
we've got JC Mangan that says Zach
LaVine two plus threes
kb225 with maybe the most bold play that
I've seen in this chat so far Ben
Simmons over six and a half points he
can get that by accident no he can't no
he can't
I'm sorry if that I'm sorry if that
laugh came in real loud bro there's no
way no way that's like accident accident
yeah
hell no uh spicy sponge says no chat we
know if RR likes cam Thomas it's a fade
okay
Triple R
so it's a good thing it's a good thing I
got the I got the shades on uh a lot of
Cam Thomas love which is hard to to root
against miguelito 11 says Nick Claxton
over 15 and a half points a lot of
lots of swishing no dishing
listen I I I think that we need to start
this with Cam Thomas he's one of the
best stories right now so
I don't know if we're going all the way
up for 30 35 points but I'm down a bit
to get it cracking with that
no yeah cam Thomas's this team this
Brooklyn Nets team is possibly about to
turn to his team
it's possibly going to turn to his team
I think he's going to make a statement
tonight
so are we doing the regular 25
25. I think 25 is good over 25 and a
half I see Trigger away trigger weight
uh is in the comments and 20 over 25.
I see why ree says cam Thomas Points
Plus assist plus reap pra let's just say
pra people over 40.
what do we feel better about do we feel
well because that's tough because that's
actually tough I don't know do we tease
it down to 20 do we do the thing do we
do the thing and just tease it down we
threw the rule book out
yeah we definitely knew us 25 is a good
number if you want to use the 26 that's
fine
um listen I can tell you from what I
watch every single Bulls game there is
defense is not very good he's going to
be volume shooting he's basically the
only option that they have that's a
reliable score tonight he's going to
have at least 25 I would say all right
hear me out hear me out are we locking
this in we locked it in lock it in
you got something Greg
vucevic
which is
over 12 rebounds that's
that's kind of a lot of rebalance I will
be fine with 10 he is a walking
Double-Double I think he's got almost 40
this year so if we can meet in the
middle at 10 I like that play what's
what's the odds right uh
hold on let's see uh you're you're
pushing here propaganda I can I can see
it
it's building up my yeah the wheels are
turning the wheels are turning let me
just let me just say I want to shout out
Dairy in85 because I always give him uh
some crap in this chat but he's
self-policing the chat letting them know
it's only TNT games shout out darian85
and he reminded me we can't parlay Pras
so daring 85 you get a gold star for
today congratulations
the odds they look fine I see sea world
vusevich over three and a half assists
is hit in the last six games pre-show I
told you that was my lock four assists
for vuchevich so we're gonna throw them
in there that's gonna be like all right
scratch the rebounds go to the assist
I'm filling the vibes
let's go
the mic there
the people are calling this the Michael
bowling like we have we had a Michael
bowling leg yet no wait no we have
wait no wait no way no way no way no
that's it this is not a Michael Brian
there you go like there you go what
about your agenda what am I doing this
is not a Michael bowling lick bowling
I'm giving you love this is I'm because
when this cash is in the first quarter
I'm gonna say Michael bowling the Greek
god of betting
Michael bowling just read a comment that
said something about that said something
about this there are four few worlds
this could not be
exactly you see come on bowling me and
you we're a line we're aligned this
cannot be bowling's play if it came from
the people Greg do you know why I know
we're aligned because we're men of the
people come on talk to him talk to him
Originals Originals you know what I'm
saying Ryan I don't know if you know
what that is
[Laughter]
uh I like I like I like the chat the
Chad's vibing today what do you guys
think about Royce O'Neill over 10 points
it's minus 115. you're seeing that from
uh ovl Rose yes sir
I don't hate it he gave us a lot of
alarms
shout out to uh Kelly Bean saying the
it's the Chicago over everything leg
that is very much belay we love to see
it shout out Kelly Bean
uh
and Sea World you will get a shout out
if vusevich uh cashes because that was
your play and we're just the line that's
how you talk to the people Ryan as a man
of the people you know what I'm saying I
level set with the people
that's it they want to give me a hard
time I'm going to give them a hard time
that's just how we do it here it's tough
love it's it's love but it's tough love
Ryan all right so how do we how do we
feel about Royce O'Neal he's a he's a
sharpshooter I think he's gonna make a
bunch of threes
let's do it let's I mean are we acting
brand new or are we not acting brand new
like Greg but but Greg acting brand new
doesn't mean we say yes to everything
you know
I mean maybe we usually say no to
everything so maybe you know I see
Thomas see Thomas 110 said again Zach
Levine two plus threes
he said he said a bunch of games in a
row with two threes
um he would he was dangled in uh trade
talks today with the Knicks he is
obviously still on the Bulls
I like him to make two he always shows
up in New York
um I don't I'm very cautious though guys
like I've been I've seen this movie
before Oh no if you guys are gonna hate
me even more if the Bulls don't come
through so I'm down to put it in it is a
very strong play and I guess I will take
the blame if the Bulls kind of stroke us
tonight but I hate him even more bowling
we don't this is love this is no hate
this is love I'm just a very I am just a
very damaged and sad Bulls fan and I
don't want you guys to end up upset
because of it
that's fair maybe we don't do this then
it's a strong play I will say you guys
make the final call he's hit two threes
in a bunch of games in a row and he's
gonna minus 400 right yeah it's minus
400.
lock it in and we've been we've been
cooked on minus 400 before
[Laughter]
right here goes Ryan
DeRozan is likely out so he's gonna get
a Lion's Share of the touches so I think
it's a good play I'm willing how about
this I I'd be more willing to go back to
Royce O'Neill 10 points and play that
instead of this if we're okay with that
come on let's do it all right are we
okay with that bowling I I don't want I
don't want there to be too much pressure
on your Chicago Bulls
yeah we can't take any more pressure man
because we're just bad
there's also another game yes and we got
okay so just so we know LeBron James is
out tonight for the Los Angeles Lakers
that I know for sure because I had to
redo
oh I think I seen that in here too
somebody said a d for 30 while you guys
go through
I'm gonna go find it so I can give him
his props because
Elias parlay said A.D over 30 points
that's a big number but he's got to do
it
I yeah
exactly you're right he was pissed off
last game he was pissed off I don't know
what's going on like he was pissed off I
think he comes back
I think I know what was up and this is
just my personal Theory
when you stop a game for the celebration
it's all deserved I'm not gonna hate on
LeBron James in here but if you stop a
game and you're down 10 to the Thunder I
don't know how you can be excited you
just can't it's hard
and they like hey Brian can you go to uh
80s 30 points please yes sir sorry I was
trying to push uh Buck's money line
yeah I know I caught you I caught you
beforehand it's what I do yeah it is
what I do I gotta I gotta get creative I
gotta get more slick with it no in all
honesty though I would not be opposed to
putting that into the Parlor I know you
wouldn't I think we'll juice this up I
think we'll juice this up if we get some
Lakers props in here and then pick the
books oh yeah oh yeah
wonder why
this makes me feel like we need to throw
Giannis 30 in there latiana's 30 love in
here
Giannis get gotta get Giannis on The
Ticket listen no Thomas Bryant ad is
gonna have to do a ton of scoring he
might be tired he's still just getting
back from his injury I think Giannis
could get 30 by like the third quarter
and this game might not be that close I
was gonna say my only concern is if this
is a blowout we might not get
but also who who is going to score that
much for the bucks you know that's what
I'm saying we watched the Bucks last
week and Giannis went berserk
yeah
technical foul in the comments what
happened Sea World Sea World literally
the first line one of the first lines I
said on this show is Grayson Allen and
Brooke Lopez
are on the betting ban list why are we
dropping Grayson Allen prop bets in the
chat
we need a whistle
a little whistle you you took the words
right out of my mouth I was literally
about to say I need a whistle I need a
whistle that's a flagrant too
that's that's a that's a clear path now
yeah
oh no what's the new foul what's the
Newfoundland translation
[Laughter]
yeah no I think the I think the chat
loves Giannis so I'm kind of down with
that I mean he's averaging more than 30.
that's fine what just put your
propaganda
go Giannis go Bucks
yeah
I I my thing was oh we're at 6 17 or
this is you guys know this is the area I
like uh if we throw if we throw bucks
money line in there that's gonna put us
at what 700 this is Imagine imagine
putting Lakers money line in there
though no man what are you talking about
what oh man look what that would do
and at that point it's like just take
Lakers minus two and a half just go
alternate just knew us knew us do we
need to fade ourselves do we need to
just do we need to redo everything that
we just done and take the opposite no no
I like this part way right now yeah I
think we're in a good spot I think we're
in a good spot everybody shut up
that's that's good vibes that's really
good vibes lock it in just bet it now
that's so good
we have to I'm gonna bet it right now
I'm literally taking my phone out and
betting it right now screenshot
screenshot
777. Ryan we're locking this in bro are
we
that's the best number you can get bro
bro
that's like Immaculate Vibes Immaculate
Vibes Sea World Sea World did just drop
I know we talked about no Brook Lopez
but he reminded us that Thomas Bryant
sounds 80 has no help
let's go
can we can we see what the Yeah Yeah so
so we have yanis 30 plus points we have
bucks money line
we have in the early game cam Thomas 25
plus points uh vuchevich over three and
a half assists and Royce O'Neill over
nine and a half points five legs plus
seven seven
seven seven yeah
this is marvelous this is so good yeah
uh
Brian no no no don't do it no no don't
do it Ryan don't you dare do it we're
locking it in we're locking it in let's
lock it in Ryan review it one more time
for the people
yeah it's plus 777 bro but if we take
down Camp Thomas to 20 20 plus points no
no
every everyone in the world in the world
is going to bet cam Thomas is over
points tonight you know that we know
that yo that was our first leg why are
we talking about it because look it's
not seven seven anymore it's not 777
anymore it's plus eight three eight so
maybe if we take it down to 20 plus it
gets down to seven seven we'll never
know all right all right all right all
right all right all of a sudden all of a
sudden I'm making good I mean I'm just a
Vibe guy I'm big Vibe guy I see 777 I
like it all right let's take down let's
take down the parlay because we're about
to adjust we're about to adjust
get a shoe all right I hope you're I
hope you're having better luck than me
because I I'm saying giannis's points
are locked right now
really I'm kind of worried about it yeah
okay
we didn't get it back to 777 but the
chat is telling me that plus 566 is an
even luckier number okay
lock it in you're a nut bro you're so
funny I don't see that anywhere so
everyone that's in the chat supposedly
put that in there this is how you know
that Ryan is a rat and not around the
people because I don't see it anywhere
literally nowhere
what are you talking about
oh I must be blind I got my blind
glasses on so
I like it he's gonna score 20 for sure
59 559 hey Ryan let's check the channel
I think we'll lock it in
I think
yeah yeah
right I mean
yeah
let's read it cam Thomas 20 plus points
nikolavuchovic over three and a half
assists shout out me for the
pronunciation there Royce O'Neill over
nine and a half points Giannis 30 plus
points Milwaukee Bucks money line
there it is no concerns wait a second
now nope oh yeah all right you got it
you got it you got it okay
I'm sorry MB
you good all right here we go if you
guys want to tell our five leg parlay
make sure you head on over to FanDuel
and opt into the TNT Thursdays no sweat
parlay
for a free bet if it loses all right we
we're grading two let's grade some bets
like two two three and get on the body
here it's time to win some money oh sir
Ryan do you see any bets that we should
grade into the comments oh I was just I
was just looking at Don Don Jean saying
566 is a better number shout out you
because you know bowling's over here
saying he didn't see it I see two
comments in here that's way later man
you also had a burner account in here
confirming yeah it's luck here so this
is all just propaganda dude it's always
propaganda why do we do every week we
walk in here and we're like oh we're
surprised by Ryan's Pro it's always
propaganda it's never not been
propagated
um I've said this multiple times on
these live shows that we do never said I
was a man of integrity right and I've
never not said that the stuff I'm
pushing is an agenda of propaganda it's
just what it is
but uh
all right we need a squad ride in there
so this is this is what we need
um spicy sponge said good luck Shades if
we hit this parlay do we have to do
sunglasses from now on every every week
yes every week I mean why not The Vibes
I mean we're I don't even see any bets
in here to grade uh Brian read the
poorly for the people that just came
into the show
you just like having me do this don't
you this is I mean
what or you could just tell them to
screenshot it yeah I mean what kind of
sick pleasure do you get from me reading
this like six or seven times Greg but
here here it is here it is screenshot it
cam Thomas 20 plus points nikolavuchovic
over three and a half assists Royce
O'Neill over nine and a half points
Giannis 30 plus points Milwaukee Bucks
money line plus 559
screenshot it
screenshot
screenshot it uh we do need we do need a
squad ride though so we need to oh uh
don don Jean uh who was the one who said
566 is a luckier number said A.D over
nine and a half rebounds thought
thoughts he does have no help tonight so
he might be the only guy you know
sucking him up like a vacuum I'm gonna
assume pause I'm gonna assume that uh
that number is pretty inflated so is
that going to be it worth anything
I don't know
hold on
did I throw you my bad
is it I I heard it in my head and I was
like do I say it out loud
if you say it I'm Gonna Catch You So
don't you worry about that
how are we how it's his can we show can
we show the odds no we show the odds
it's at 13 and a half
how are we how how are we dropping nine
and a half rebounds when it's at 13 and
a half
that's that's wild
Sea World Sea World dropped uh Bucks win
plus 11 win margin that's some stuff
there
uh shell centerfolds
cam Thomas three plus threes I'm okay
with this being a cam Thomas tonight
just continue to ride the wave
listen we give up a lot of them that
might be a good bet
what's this I hope it's just add to over
two and a half it might be three and a
half
two and a half times is I'm looking for
cam Thomas stuff that's a good game
that's a good bet I would take that like
I said earlier
that Nets team might be his team now
so it certainly is I mean like we
already know Ben Simmons isn't going to
be anything like that
um I would say it is his team honestly
the Nets the Whole Net situation is not
that bad they're not gonna make they're
not gonna make any noise this year but
Bridges and Johnson are both good
players they're gonna have picks like I
don't know give them some time they
might be decent they're not gonna make
the playoffs either
um but yeah
no we'll see Ryan that's going to make
it
we'll see about that
shout out shout out to Shell's
centerfold I think we're locking that in
cam Thomas over two and a half threes
minus 128 Logan
screenshot
screenshot screenshot screenshot there
it is that's a squad wide that is Wilbur
Rockaway the parlay uh there it is
screenshot that's the parlay that's what
we're rocking with you want to read it
I'm sorry do you want to read the parlay
no no I want them
screenshot
you know what I mean yeah
yeah screenshot let's get on the body
here because uh I'm trying to win some
money I am trying to win some money uh
my name is Greg Ivory next to me is the
man I like to call MB Michael Bolin the
man of the app and next to him Double R
producer Ryan we are out of here
peace
guys thank you guys in New York
foreign
[Music]